so there are more developments in the
Democratic primary just a week before
the first Democratic debates which are
next Wednesday and Thursday there are
now two recent polls in which Elizabeth
Warren has actually pulled ahead of
Bernie Sanders in the second place and
this is absolutely fascinating in terms
of just the dynamics of the primary
going into the debate it's fascinating
in terms of the sort of progressive
front and runner status that Bernie
Sanders has had and in the average still
continues to have with the exception of
these two polls and and that's what I
want to be clear about in an average of
recent polls Bernie Sanders is still
solidly in second place ahead of
Elizabeth Warren by an average of about
three percentage points but it is
getting very close okay so on this chart
Joe Biden is the top Green Line and I'll
describe to you the numbers so if you're
listening and not watching don't worry
Bernie Sanders is the light blue line
and Elizabeth Warren is the brown line
in third place now to quickly reset
you'll notice Joe Biden spiked to 42
when he announced he was running for
president he trailed off more and more
has continued to decline now down to an
average of 32 almost down to where he
was pre-announcement and down about 10
points from his high early on it was
Bernie Sanders who was gaining from Joe
Biden's declines and you'll see that for
a period of time Bernie was climbing
basically in parallel with Joe Biden's
decline about 80 percent of Joe Biden's
decline early on went to Bernie Sanders
and as I told you at the start of this
week Bernie's climbs have slowed and in
fact Bernie Sanders has actually started
to trail off a little bit in recent
polls from closer to 18 down to 15
recently and it is Elizabeth Warren
who's still slow and steady has picked
up another point or so and is solidly at
12% more interesting though is that
there are two recent polls that actually
straight up have Elizabeth Warren ahead
of Bernie Sanders now we're putting this
up on the screen now for our video
audience in a recent Monmouth poll
released yesterday Elizabeth Warren is
now up 15 to 14 over Bernie Sanders now
yes it's within the margin of error in
an economists poll released just a few
days ago Elizabeth Warren is up
sixteen to 12 over Bernie Sanders
starting to get to the edges of the
margin of error so these are just two
polls Bernie Sanders is still ahead of
Elizabeth Warren in most polls the
margin of error matters but this is a
change from two months ago if you go to
two months ago Bernie was averaging 22
and Elizabeth Warren was at five or six
Bernie was quadrupling Elizabeth Warren
two months ago and now they're almost
effectively tied within the margin of
error with Elizabeth Warren in the lead
in a couple of polls so I like Bernie
Sanders I like Elizabeth Warren what I
like about this is the way that
Elizabeth Warren is doing this she has
come from behind with a policy and
substance campaign which I love no ad
homonyms no flash no even massive media
coverage really nothing other than just
diving deep on policy explaining to
people why her ideas are as far as she's
concerned the solutions to the problems
that we're facing as a country and I
think that this makes the debates that
are starting next week even more
interesting you might remember that
because there are I guess 20 Democratic
candidates who have qualified for the
first debate on the basis of either
65,000 donors from at least 20 different
states I believe it is some minimum
number from each state or at least 1% in
three polls there are 20 candidates in
total who have qualified on the basis of
one or the other of those standards many
would not have qualified if they were
both requirements but because it is one
or the other there are 20 candidates
participating in the debates that start
next week that is so many that they have
split the debate into two parts night a
and night B Wednesday and Thursday
interestingly Elizabeth Warren is on
night a separated from all of the other
frontrunners she's separated from Biden
who's on night B she's separate from
Bernie she's separate from Budaj
and Harris that is potentially a great
opportunity for Elizabeth Warren to be
the lone frontrunner on what is
officially the first night of debate in
the Democratic primary it also could be
maybe something that will hurt Elizabeth
Warren in the sense that she will
even be on the same stage as all of the
other frontrunners and maybe will be
sort of incorrectly be seen as being at
the kids table so to speak even though
that is not how it is being divided up
in this particular debate so we'll see
but what I will be addressing on the
Friday show tomorrow relates to whether
the fact that both Warren and Bernie are
the progressive hand that it's so to
speak and are in second and third place
respectively is that in some way going
to weaken the progressive movement
against the centrist candidate the
establishment candidate Joe Biden will
talk about that tomorrow and I want to
hear from you do you think that
Elizabeth Warren being separated from
the and when I say being separated not
proactively as far as we know by the DNC
this is how the draw happened to come
out if we take their word for it which
many of us don't but many many of us do
at least to some degree will this hurt
her or will this help her I want to hear
from you about this issue one of today's
sponsors is impeach the card slap game
you can't slap Donald Trump in real life
but you can slap him in this really
funny and intelligent two-player card
game and you can get it for ten percent
off when you go to david pakman.com
slash impeach and use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout all one word
impeach the card slap game is perfect
for having friends over or hanging out
with family members who have a sense of
humor about Trump we've been playing it
at my place it currently has a five out
of five star rating on Amazon I really
don't think you'll be able to find a
game that does a better job of
satirizing today's political climate in
such an intelligent way I've had a ton
of fun with it and I think you will too
you can tell a ton of time and careful
thought went into the game design and
the cartoon artwork and the humor it
never gets old because you're always
discovering new jokes and political
commentary within the game we were
talking to the creators of the game and
they said one of their goals was that
players might even learn something new
as they play I think it would make a
perfect gift for anyone really of any
political orientation just because of
how clever it is or you can get it for
your
self and have a really fun and witty
game to play when people come over get
impeach the cards slap game by going to
david pakman.com slash impeach and get
10% off when you use the coupon code
pakman show at checkout that's all one
word Pakman show